[Musica]
ci sono dei momenti nella vita in cui
dobbiamo fare delle scelte che
decideranno del nostro futuro
a volte sono momenti pieni di entusiasmo
più spesso sono pieni di dubbi ed
incertezze
voi vi ricordate quando da adolescenti
avete scelto il vostro lavoro o il
vostro percorso di studi beh io ero
molto indecisa perché c'era questa
materia informatica che mi incuriosiva
molto io ero appassionata di videogiochi
ma non sapevo assolutamente cosa fosse
in realtà perché all'epoca beh un mi era
tecnologica passata non avevo nemmeno un
computer a casa non esistevano nemmeno i
telefonini e non intendo gli smartphone
intendo quei telefonini e da 2 kg che
telefonava dei bastard
in questo mio momento di indecisione
personale ricordo il giorno in cui il
mio professore di matematica in quinta
liceo ci chiese cosa volevamo fare dopo
bachi rispose prima di matisse economia
matematica i suoi commenti erano
incoraggianti se si troverà bene non
aveva problemi
poi arrivò mai un po titubante gli dissi
ingegneria informatica e lui disse
canale live a nella fossa dei leoni
stavo per dirgli che scherzavo poi per
la giunta beh lei è ben equipaggiata
veda scapperanno il leone e così mi sono
iscritto
e ricordo il primo giorno di lezione
all'università e la sensazione di
entrare in quell'aula di quasi 300
persone guardarmi intorno e chiedermi ma
dove sono finite le donne facciamo
elezioni separate no in realtà erano
l'altro che non erano tante le si notava
molto ma ero sicura di una cosa convinta
che
la situazione sarebbe cambiata i tempi
stanno cambiando e le donne aumenteranno
beh a voi lo posso dire
era il 1996 e io non avevo capito niente
perché le percentuali di iscritte
informatica in italia non stavano
aumentando anzi stavano calando
drammaticamente eravamo quasi un quarto
delle scritte al primo corso che ha
perse tale che per in italia a pisa e
poi le percentuali
continuano a salire fino a quasi un
terzo fino al 1981 poi negli anni 90 un
drastico calo fino a un misero 9 per
cento
sette anni fa e da lì stiamo lentamente
cercando di risalire
potreste chiedervi in fondo se questo
poi sia davvero un problema
ci sono dei settori in cui le donne sono
la maggioranza
è vero però è in questo settore che nel
prossimo futuro si apriranno
straordinarie opportunità di lavoro e
tra così adesso la commissione europea
ci parla di centinaia di migliaia di
nuovi posti di lavoro in questo campo
già a partire dai prossimi anni beh io
penso che metà di quei posti di lavoro
le donne se lo dovrebbero andare a
prendere è un diritto ma anche più di
questo è un dovere non solo un dovere
nei confronti di noi stessi per
un'opportunità da non perdere ma anche
un dovere nei confronti della società
oggi l'innovazione e il progresso hanno
bisogno di idee
il limite non è più la tecnologia che
ormai ci permette di fare qualunque cosa
il limite è la mancanza di idee di
fantasia di creatività per trovare
soluzioni nuove
beh ecco in questo senso perdere il
contributo delle donne che sono una meta
molto creativa della popolazione non ce
lo possiamo permettere
in alcuni paesi le donne stanno già
andando a prendersi quei posti di lavoro
ma non credo che siano i paesi a cui
state pensando
c'è questo studio scientifico che
analizza le percentuali di donne
nell'informatica e nelle scienze
tecnologiche nei paesi del mondo
beh il risultato abbastanza sorprendente
perché i paesi con i più alti livelli di
politiche per la parità di genere sono i
paesi come quelli del nord europa che
hanno le percentuali di donne in questo
settore più basse mentre i paesi dove le
discriminazioni contro le donne e la
disparità di genere sono storicamente
più forti come gli emirati arabi la
turchia l'algeria sono quelli che hanno
le percentuali più alte il discorso
meriterebbe di essere approfondito ma
una spiegazione che danno i ricercatori
molto semplice nei paesi arabi in cui le
donne stanno cercando di rialzare la
testa
le donne stanno cercando la via più
facile per l'indipendenza economica e
quindi vanno proprio in un settore che
da tante opportunità di lavoro ma perché
in italia in europa le donne non
scelgono l'informatica io non sono una
psicologa e non ho la pretesa di avere
la risposta è un discorso complesso
sicuramente c'è un fenomeno culturale la
tecnologia viene vista come una cosa da
maschi probabilmente tanti fattori
insieme sicuramente mancano le figure
femminili di riferimento
immagino che chiunque di voi saprebbe
facilmente dirmi il nome di un uomo
famoso nel campo dell'informatica ma
quanti di voi saprebbero dire il nome di
una donna e poi non ce ne sono tante ma
la mia preferita è lei
grasshopper 48 kg di pura tenacia
laureata in matematica
durante la seconda guerra mondiale vuole
dare il suo contributo al paese ma i
paesi né fisicamente per essere adorata
nella marina militare
quindi si arruola come volontaria nella
riserva della marina e li ha l'occasione
di lavorare su uno dei primi computer
della storia dal suo lavoro poi nascerà
anche un nuovo linguaggio di
programmazione il cobol che ancora usato
oggi ed è lei a definire per la prima
volta il termine bug informatico
come mai il funzionamento del software
in inglese bug significa proprio insetto
perché fu letteralmente una falena che
se anche è stata nei circuiti di un
computer che lei stessa tolse beh questa
piccola grande donna ha dato una
definizione dell'informatica
estremamente semplice programmare è come
preparare una cena devi pianificare
tutto pensare alla sequenza delle cose
in modo da avere tutto pronto quando ti
serve è il concetto è così semplice
bisognerebbe spiegarlo così a tutti a
partire da bambini e bambine perché oggi
sull'informatica in realtà c'è scarsa
conoscenza
il che è un po un paradosso se ci
pensate
siamo tutti immersi nell'informatica
passiamo ore davanti ai teleschermi di
telefonini di computer però pochi sanno
cosa vuol dire farla veramente perché
siamo sempre utilizzatori e non creatori
ed è un peccato non provare la
differenza perché io lo vedo negli occhi
dei miei studenti il momento quello
dello stupore quando schiacciano quel
tasto che dà l'avvio al loro primo
programma e il computer fa qualcosa che
hanno deciso loro che è unico e che un
attimo prima non esisteva e con la
voglia di far capire questa sensazione
alle ragazze
sei anni fa abbiamo provato a fare
qualcosa di concreto con l'università di
modena e reggio emilia e con
un'associazione femminile del territorio
e vuoi b
abbiamo pensato a un summer camp un camp
estivo riservato alle ragazze di 16 18
anni e l'abbiamo chiamato ragazze
digitali
abbiamo pensato come possiamo far capire
quanto l'informatica può essere creativo
e divertente
abbiamo pensato a un attività che lo
fosse abbiamo pensato a un videogioco
completamente fatto da loro programmato
con un vero linguaggio di programmazione
ma molte ragazze partono d'azzardo
competere
quindi bisognava dare in un po ci voleva
un po di tempo quindi abbiamo pensato a
un summer camp di quattro settimane di
un mese molti dicevano dato dei motti
quale ragazzina a giugno appena finita
la scuola verrebbe l'università a fare
informatica invece andare in piscina
però loro sono venuta è stata la prima
edizione 2014 a modena 40 ragazze circa
alla fine abbiamo chiesto loro cosa
avrebbero cambiato è rimasta indelebile
nella mia memoria
una risposta che hanno dato alcune
avremmo voluto più tempo per migliorare
il nostro progetto e quindi forti di
questo e abbiamo rifatto
l'anno dopo l'anno dopo ancora e lo
faccio anche oggi
l'ambiente è volutamente informale
imparano facendo e sbagliando le ragazze
l'avevano in gruppo
ogni gruppo sceglie la sua team leader
che poi presenterà il progetto si
dividono i ruoli i compiti
ogni gruppo sviluppa un progetto diverso
dagli altri scelgono il tema del gioco
la storia disegnano la grafica personali
sono tutti gli elementi negli ultimi
anni possono anche programmare robottini
con arduino e controllarli da un'app col
telefonino
beh non vi nascondo che è una faticaccia
tenerlo in piedi ogni anno
pubblicizzarlo organizzarlo e cercare i
fondi per pagare tutto perché si non vi
ho detto una cosa importante per le
ragazze che partecipano è completamente
gratuito
mi piace dirlo perché questo lo rende
unico in italia ma anche all'estero però
l'energia spesa per farlo è ripagata dal
loro entusiasmo e anche dal cambiamento
che vediamo in loro perché le vediamo
arrivare all'inizio un po intimorita e
poi li vedi l'ultimo giorno che
presentano i progetti soddisfatte e
orgogliose davanti a un'aula magna piena
siano espressioni bolden brillant in
realtà brillanti lo erano anche quando
sono arrivate
noi ne abbiamo rese solo un po più
audaci hanno capito che possono
competere in un campo che fino al giorno
prima vedevano di esclusivo appannaggio
maschile
ricordo un videogioco fatto da un gruppo
di ragazze del liceo classico qualche
anno fa l'hanno chiamato pena europea si
è la storia di penelope che si stanca di
tessere la tela e aspettare liste e
quindi parte per mare affronta la mostra
sfide
abbiamo dotato le principesse di armi
per che salvasse e mi è piaciuto molto
il messaggio che abbiamo chiesto alle
ragazze volevano dare con questo
videogioco lo hanno detto che le donne
hanno in mano il loro destino e sta a
loro cambiarlo se non sono soddisfatte
questo ci è piaciuto molto e così summer
camp pian piano è cresciuto tutti gli
anni
adesso lo facciamo su pensieri oltre a
modena reggio emilia e cesena
l'anno scorso abbiamo avuto 172 ragazze
quelli che vedete sono i loghi delle
singole edizioni disegnati e scelti
dalle ragazze stesse è un po come se
ogni anno creassimo un piccolo paese un
paese dove l'informatica e donna e voi
potete aiutarci a far crescere questo
paese
se vi piace l'idea suggerite lo ha
un'amica una figlia a una nipote o
magari qualcuno di voi potrebbe provare
a replicarlo nella propria città ne
saremmo felici di darvi tutto il
supporto ma la verità è che un paese
così possiamo farlo crescere ben oltre
il summer camp tutti noi tutti insieme
giorno per giorno come fare beh iniziamo
così usciti da qui ditte alle giovani
donne questa cosa da parte mia non
abbiate paura di rischiare usate anche
quando la sfida sembra difficile vedrete
siete ben equipaggiate scapperanno i
leoni grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]